hello professor do poche yes my name is
Adam Smith calling from nobelprize.org
and congratulations thank you very much
it must be quite a day you're suffering
yes still at the University of London
somebody is taking care of me well up so
they that's nice yeah okay so just a
couple of quick questions you have been
awarded in part because of your
development of vitrification of water
and people try so people know about
liquid water and they know about ice but
I guess most people don't know about
vitrified water yes if you cool water
it's become eyes it would be great if
you could cool the water and immobilize
the molecules so keeping the structure
because when it's frozen when it's
immobilized you can have it in the
electron microscope and the water will
not evaporate because in the electron
microscope it must be on the vacuum and
water at root normal temperature
evaporates so that when it was possible
to vitrified biological materials you
could have it in the microscope in the
vitrified state and observe it quietly
in the electron microscope this was the
beginning and so if you had have it in
ice or if you have it without water the
the molecules like fish or dead yes
beautifully said and this the Nobel
Prize will put a lot of public attention
on you how do you feel about that and
about the responsibility of scientists
who interact with the public that's
interesting I've been during the 20
years I was at the University of
Lausanne I devoted a lot of effort to
curriculum biology and society and
London at that time was unique
in developing this curriculum for all
our student it was not a kind of
additional piece of education it was a
core program in the study of biology and
it still continues tomorrow morning I
give a talk at that course and the idea
of this course is to make make sure that
our students are as good citizen as they
are good biologist I can tell you that
this is very close to my to my heart
how wonderful so in a way for 20 years
you've been preparing for this role good
lovely can we look forward to welcoming
you to Stockholm in December
[Laughter]
[Music]
well we anticipate your arrival with
great excitement thank you very much
indeed and once again